Speaker 1: OK, last thing on again, every
day we are learning more about the insanity
that took place in the aftermath of the November
election and in the lead up to the Jan. six riots.
By now, you have no doubt heard if you've been
watching my show listening to the podcast over
the last year, all of the different ways in
which they were trying to get a hold of the fact
that Joe Biden won the election and that they
wanted to try to overturn it. We've talked about
63 court filings, all of which were found to
be without merit, some to be. Some were found
where there was no standing and many of them
found to be without merit. We've learned about,
Oh, Mike Pence is going to flip the election
somehow, either by something he does himself or
by sending it back to the states or, you know,
whatever the case may be. We also heard about
declaring a national emergency slash martial
law. And there was this idea of seizing the
voting machines. Now what you do with the voting
machines, once you sees them to flip results, we
can speculate. We don't exactly know. But we now
have reason to believe that Donald Trump himself,
who is shocked by this. Donald Trump himself
was much more involved than previously known
in the plan to seize those voting machines. The
New York Times breaking the story This week,
Trump had role in weighing proposals
to seize voting machines. New accounts
show that the former president was more
directly involved than previously known in plans
developed by outside advisers to use national
security agencies to seek evidence of fraud
six weeks after Election Day, with his hold on
power slipping. Trump directed Giuliani to make
a remarkable call. Trump wanted him to ask DHS if
it could legally take control of voting machines
in key swing states, three people familiar with
the matter said. Remember that Giuliani did so,
calling the department's acting deputy
secretary, who said he lacked the authority
to audit or impound the machines. Trump
pressed Giuliani to make the inquiry
after rejecting a separate effort by his outside
advisers to have the Pentagon take control of
the machines. And the outreach to the Department
of Homeland Security came not long after Trump,
in an Oval Office meeting with then-Attorney
General William Barr, raised the possibility
of whether the Justice Department could seize the
machines. A previously undisclosed suggestion that
Mr Barr immediately shot down the new accounts
show that Trump was more directly involved than
previously known in exploring these proposals to
seize voting machines as he grasped unsuccessfully
for evidence of fraud that could help him reverse
the 2020 election. Right now, everyone's attention
is focused on the coup and on election
fraud, and that makes sense. But look
at how much we've learned just about that and
then think, imagine for a moment how much other
crazy stuff was going on that we still don't
know anything about that will likely be uncovered
about the last four years. It will probably
take conservatively, another four years
to figure all of that out. And it could even
take a closer to eight to 10 years for it all
to shake out in terms of its repercussions.
It's very clear that they did attempt a coup.
But they seemed not that competent at it.
They seemed as competent at at doing the coup
as they were at governing when Donald Trump was
president, and it failed and it became a sideshow.
But we can't write it off and not worry because,
as I said earlier, DeSantis is a more competent
Trump and that makes him more dangerous. And these
same techniques now with the experience of 2020,
knowing where the hold ups were, knowing where it
ended up stalling with a more competent person at
the helm could be a very dangerous proposition.
And we've heard from retired military generals
who say if Trump had had the generals on his side
could have been a very different outcome. We've
heard about if there had been more willingness
in the House and particularly the Senate
to attempt to reject or challenge some
of the results in a more serious way
in multiple states. It could have been a different
outcome now. One more thought about this Trump
role in trying to seize voting machines. Remember
when William Barr quit seemingly out of the blue
as attorney general on December
23rd, December 23rd was the date
of William Barr's resignation letter. Did
William Barr see the writing on the wall
about what was coming on January 6th? Maybe not
specifically, but knowing this is potentially bad,
and I don't want to be associated with it.
And that's why he abruptly quit. Because if
you consider the timing, the meetings where
the idea of a national emergency was floated,
the meetings where the question about can we seize
the voting machines? All of this stuff happened
between the November election and December 23rd
when William Barr quit. And it seems plausible,
at least, that Barr knew or suspected that
something insane was coming and decided to
get the hell out of there before. It doesn't make
Barr any better of an attorney general. It's just
Barr acting out of self-interest. The timing makes
sense at some point. Maybe we'll know for sure